Ronni the limo driver just shot two days
on some TV show playing in Ibiza playing
an FBI agent you know what but but he's
in his FBI outfit I got a picture of him
here it looks like he looks like a
German warrior you know what he looks
like not the Darth Vader in Star Wars
but the Darth Vader in that Mel Brooks
baseball he looks like Darth Vader in
Spaceballs Ronny doing two days shooting
on limitless claims he claims he was
brilliant okay Michael I go Ronnie how'd
it go
great I go did they give you any notes
saying give you any feedback no I go how
many hours did shoot two days Thursday
Friday we shot a couple hours and how
many lines did he have he claims he had
lines that they hired him for the TV
show you know public waste
yeah how'd it go give Robin an update
she doesn't believe me it went really
well and how many lines is Jeb five
paragraphs oh and you memorize it or
they had a little cheat sheet no cheat
sheet no kidding yeah you can do that in
NTV you agree what do you do you read
yeah well they had like they put it like
right in front of the camera like on top
of the camera do you believe this guy do
you know the guy who mows my lawn is
gonna be on NCIS next week good to be
around you I tell ya yeah it's really
cool and then did the director give you
feedback did he say Ron emote more or a
couple of times he had to tell me too
you know enunciate a little better
louder you know did you talk did you
tell him you've acted in other things
before and he should shut the [ __ ] up oh
hey Lee Brando I was an FBI agent and
what I mean what was what about this guy
but aren't you to all that seriously I'm
not making a joke but aren't like most
guys retire from the FBI in their 40s or
50s I don't know yeah but you walked in
and they were you'll find my thing you
didn't see the picture yeah I did you
look like Darth Vader in space balls
yeah I know and what am buddy what is
your line for you give me some of your
lines I don't even remember a man give
me the scenes what was the crime no that
was the scene what the first scene I was
in on Thursday was I was being
interviewed to be in a special
okay here so so the guy of the who was
forming this task force brought me into
his office seen a guy your age who's
been in the FBI as whole life has to be
interview but was a special task force
yeah go ahead so I said I sat in the
chair and I go my character name was
month with a tee at the end I know when
I go a month I'm here you know to
interview blah blah blah blah you know
you know [ __ ] like that yeah and who
introduces some other actor yeah Jake
McDorman and then this and the second
day we shot we were rating this plant go
ahead I guess they were trying to make
the pill so you made the team yeah I was
I was the main team I was the main guy I
busted into the place a k47 and I had a
9-millimeter I was in the full flack
year nine-millimeter I don't know I
don't know if it was a two
semi-automatic yeah I don't know what it
was I see so whatever anyway um you got
that noise here dawg I was in full gear
go ahead man I tell you what those guys
I give him credit for running around
with that all that [ __ ] armed with an
ak-47 it's a heavy gun right and you're
running through this [ __ ] factory
here you know nailing people and it's
like you're tired [ __ ] yeah he put in
a good day's work
that was fun and then I was working but
if you had five paragraphs did you have
to join the union the screen actually
yeah yeah I mean you're in I'm in I mean
hey honey I'm in seg like my balls my
cockles shoot all over you right now I
mean against camera squirt a
nine-millimeter squirting all over your
face so I'm doing I'm doing the scene
with a stuntman yeah
Oh stock man this I I got a hit him in
the face with my gun oh yeah knock him
to the floor would you like you're like
Steven see ya come he comes at me with a
wrench
he's gonna hit me over the head with it
and I whack him across the face and he
goes down on the ground
Wow he was supposed to like fall over to
the left a little more than he did yeah
I fell right on top you fell on top
agent month I fell on top of you you
embarrassed that you're falling because
I know you take pride in you know why
yeah
there's 20 guys running behind me yes
we're all running in to raid the place
now it's got to all be done now I fell
down everybody hadn't stopped do you
think you could be an actor do you think
there's any trouble memorizing lines and
things like that where you think you're
ready for your close-up yeah I'm ready
I'm staying here any chance of a
spin-off series like Munt good for you
Ronnie
look at him he's on a high we're not
yelling DC well I'm doing the interview
thing did you read the script over and
over what happened was I didn't and I
improvised I had to do this Thursday
morning early Thursday morning no I
didn't get the script to like a late
Wednesday so like it's got real acting
problems you're going to give me my
sides so when I got the I said to the
guy the guy goes don't worry about it
man we got cards with you know we got
cheat sheets don't worry about yeah
you're like Brando you gotta cheat you
yeah he has his dialogue written on the
other actor everyone down on the ground
FB what's that say where's the camera
all right congratulations thanks Ronnie
on TV what's the name of the show one of
the producers starring Ronnie Monday
yeah yeah let me hear that again